you're a young director you've got John
Travolta and you're showing you how to
dance you're teaching him how to dance
I didn't have to teach John Travolta how
to dance could you does that No
oh yeah no III I wanted him to dance a
particular way it was a certain kind of
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
okay you said because it's a twist which
can be kind of boring so part of the
thing about it is I wanted Vincent and
Mia ie or mu Thurman to have two
different characters when they when they
twist alright when Vince twists I wanted
him to be kind of rich but when me a
twist the image that I had in my mind
was the zsa zsa gabor cat from the
Aristocats and there's that one little
scene with the Aristocats dance as she
kind
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we're like you do not win any awards for
being a good daughter
there are many stories where I don't
know what I was not a great daughter I
would I am forever in my mom's debt
because I was such a brat I feel really
bad about it tell us the story about
when you were on your computer and she
wanted your help
oh yes she yes okay so I I was on MSN
obviously the details we moved out like
you know out in the sticks and often
snakes would get into the house and you
know it wasn't a big deal but you just
have to like chase them around and get
it out it's kind of time-consuming in an
annoying and so my mom yelled out and
she was like can you come help me
there's this snakes really big like I
can't get it on my own can you come help
me and I was like I'm so busy mom no I
can't like just being a brat knows when
I'm missing and she was like oh I just
like hey you should please and I was
like be going and she was going for like
10 minutes and I was like oh she's been
gone for ages and then I like got up
from the computer I could hear like this
mmm and also oh god what's happening and
I see mom she's like made it halfway
down the stairs and the snake she'd
tried to like pick this big Python up
with her but with a broom and a stick
but it had wound its way up around her
arm and was going around her neck
Australia but I would never be able to
know I know I'm painting a bad picture
it's really not bad but you just want to
give it something else to climb so you
gotta stick with something it starts
weaving its way around that and then you
can transfer its weight and you grab it
behind its head you grab it behind it
okay yes fine and I tried not to be such
a brat when Mom asked for help in the
future I kind of did it a lesson learned
very good everyone says that making a
Tarantino movie isn't like making
anything else so now he's not here
what does that mean is it a good thing
it's not like anything else you know
what's funny I had heard a lot about him
and his people talked about his
mercurial way or what I don't know I I
love the guy I just think he's great I
think he's hearts in it I wish every
actor could could work for that
everything I can say is this is come
prepared to to give everything you can
think of and if you come ready to play
you're gonna have the time of your life
if you're not ready to play or if you're
lazy or if you just doesn't click or
doesn't mean that much to you then then
it's not gonna work but he has rules on
set doesn't he um yeah just a couple I
mean one of them is one of them is that
you can't bring any any device you can
turn on or off which I think it's great
I mean oh you're there to work I don't
think you should have anything yeah the
other ones a little rougher the other
one is tougher on me because I like to I
grew up sleeping on set so when I hear
people working I like to slump down in
the chair and take a nap and and as you
get older you like take more and more
naps and he won't allow sleeping on it
set so if he catches if anybody's caught
sleeping one of his rules is is that
they will slide in and put big Gerry
next to your face and take a picture of
you with big Gerry and put you on the
wall and what is big Jerry Jerry is a
dildo that's about that big
it's a purple dildo big purple dudes
yeah I don't know where it can you turn
big cherry on and off I just said
sometimes I get tired and I'd say bring
me big Jarius bastards off Brad Pitt
with big Jerry could be someone who
works on our team and they are a big
margot robbie fan and they I would I say
they're willing to do this I mean
they're very keen he's washed his feet
touched them so what is it but I mean is
it difficult to do this
Sivaji thing no are we fine yeah so Adam
your moment is here this is happening
sit down beside
I don't need to criticize my own
production team but you could have taken
your shoes and socks off first
it saves a little time you knew this
moment was coming I want to do more
video okay okay here we go here we go
you don't have to do this if you don't
want no I'm saying that he wants to do
this okay you sure yeah okay I know
there's something I have to say and this
is legally don't try this at home okay
perfect okay here we go
okay in your own time okay here we go
David um one for a while I'm sorry I'm
probably sorry that's not comforting I'm
not gonna say that wasn't very
professional I'm so scared my hands are
shaking but you don't
[Applause]
does it hurt little funny yeah don't
worry about your finest work
you just seemed happy in your work
good I like doing it
[Applause]
I'm eating it up like one we're off like
backstage
Elvis that was kind of that was an
established you as a I was gonna say
adult movie star but that makes it sound
wrong I mean that was kind of your your
big breakout role isn't it it really
that really was I mean but the thing
about it is is that when you're playing
the coca-cola can because everybody
knows what you know it's and you got
that way at the time Sarah Palin was
really well known everybody knew what
she looked like and sounded like it's
very difficult cuz that puts you give
the parameters there that you cannot go
outside of that or you start losing
weight but we I only had to be
two-dimensional you had to portray this
personally I had but I had that I had
help with the screenplay in the story
sure you know a lot going it's so all
this thing kind of crops up in your life
because one of your very first acting
roles it was with the real Elvis yeah it
was 62 something like that it was the
World's Fair and I was 10 years old and
I got this job you know to play this kid
that kicks Elvis in the shins to picking
away he wants to meet a girl a nurse so
he figures you know who gets this kid
that injure him a little bit and I kind
of hit him a little too hard and he you
know but he paid me 50 cents and then
later on when she's with him I run into
him at the fair and I say hey mister
gonna kick you in the shin again look at
her he goes get away you don't get it I
said you can do for a quarter I'll be
give me a bigger quarter I'm did you the
monkey walk
do you get that it was Elvis I mean
that's no I I was my first brush with
celebrity though I did I never I'd never
I was just a kid you know yeah it was
great it was really a nice man and he he
came on the set in the car and there
were you know the World's Fair was just
opening and so there's a lot of people
there and all of a sudden he came on the
set and maybe two or three thousand
women just went just jump the car and
bail out and come in a different way and
I thought this guy must really be famous
[Music]